earlier this year the central bank of
russia wanted to ban bitcoin bitcoin
mining and also the use of bitcoin in
any sort of transactions now of course
this is a really really abrasive way to
approach what is a decentralized digital
currency that happens to be getting
global adoption by hundreds of millions
of people around the world well now
they've changed their tune and what
we're seeing is that the russian
government has actually reached a
resolution they don't want to ban it
they simply want to regulate it and so
the russian ministry of finance has
submitted a complete bill to regulate
bitcoin to the cabinet of ministers now
what exactly is in this bill well first
here's the press release that announced
that this was actually getting put
forward what we see is that the ministry
of finance has sent a draft federal law
called on digital currency to the
government of russia what they're
looking for is feedback and ultimately
approval now inside of the bill there's
basically three key components that you
need to know of what russia is trying to
do with bitcoin the first is that they
want to treat crypto as an investment
tool not legal tender they say that
cryptocurrencies may not be used to pay
for goods or services they also want all
sorts of different crypto businesses
whether you're an exchange or an
over-the-counter desk to satisfy certain
criteria to obtain a license and also be
registered with the government and
lastly foreign crypto exchanges must
register as legal entities in russia to
provide services in the country as well
now ultimately this is a little wonky
you're going to actually recognize
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies as
investment tools but not allow them to
be used for the purchase of good or
services that's weird to me
ultimately you can't stop the use of
bitcoin for the purchase of goods and
services bitcoin is a store value it's a
medium of exchange and it is a unit of
account just like any other currency
only in a decentralized way no one can
stop it no one can shut it down and so
ultimately this is a step in the right
direction the russian government is
sitting there saying look this is going
to be a thing we need to get ahead of it
we want to be able to regulate and
they're creating a framework a set of
rules that people will need to follow
but ultimately i think that the citizens
of russia and others around the world
are going to use bitcoin as a medium of
exchange and a unit of account and so
those rules are likely to change
eventually the russian government will
recognize bitcoin not only as an
investment option but also as a medium
of exchange for goods and services and
eventually as a unit of account bitcoin
is inevitable and the russian government
realizes that bitcoin is good for
business so it's great to see them
embracing it creating a set of rules i
just think that they're going to
continue to expand those rules over time